es stimmt mir und ihr dumm ist
zeitspringen daran schuld schließlich
waren wir gestern noch im park dreht
sich einfach dafür dass das problem
nicht gar nicht mehr
ich suche mir dann mal einen anderen
planeten zum beruf leute ist es nicht
ein wunderschöner tag die sonne scheint
draußen blauer himmel ich schaue youtube
trends platz eins ist nicht abstoßend
dieses mal unfassbar deutsche frau anja
knapp gis cool aber moment mal was ist
das bekommt dann nachricht auf install
bitte mach ein video darüber könnten wir
den link hinführt
[Musik]
aber wisst ihr was leute als fleißiger
und als ehrenwerte youtuber drückt man
sich nicht davor wenn du einen zuschauer
ein hilf mir geschickt dann muss man
sich das auch anschauen und auch und ich
will persönlich bei dem titel mein
freund mästet mich denke eigentlich muss
nicht sagen wir machen es trotzdem für
euch meine schatten
[Musik]
okay das ganze situation wir haben hier
eine junge dame mit solchen die auf der
couch schild daneben ist ein junger
etwas schmächtiger mann wer hat herr zu
dem fall dagegen entschieden den t shirt
anzuziehen und hat sich eine halbe
packung chips auf die brust gekippt mal
gucken was es damit auf sich hat warum
klicke ich eigentlich immer wieder auf
diese videos wir haben gerade mal 13
sekunden geschaut leute und es ist
wieder so haben ja schwer zu übersehen
du hast dir wirklich viel mühe dabei
gegeben fucking packung lebensmittel auf
den oberkörper zu schütten was ist
eigentlich mit dir das sind lieber alle
latten am zaun oder sind es so städten
mit sahne
ich dachte ich hätte nach dem arsch
operation video alles gesehen heute
ich kann wirklich liebst du mich
eigentlich noch ich tue es doch alles
nur für dich
sein don't often du bist doch meine
große liebe ich will alles ganz gut zwei
dinge ich finde in diese szene sieht
dieser tipp ein bisschen aus wie embargo
kennt ihr den march wären wir ein paar
mal getroffen ich bleibe meinem bild ich
bin schon vor einiger auch abgebaut sein
gesicht dass diese seien aber du bist
doch meine große liebe ich bin so
verliebt sein gesichtsausdruck er so
kleine rote das halt wir original liegt
mir so man meistens gibt man lachen oder
weinen soll über diesen videos kurz
darauf seid ashley mit louis zusammen
ist hat sich die 19-jährige sehr
verändert was nicht nur auf begeisterung
stößt der sprecher so erklärt sich
verändert das ist irgendwie alles stürzt
nicht immer auf begeisterung und dann
trifft sie so eine freundin wieder und
die freundin erst mal zu schreiben also
so kraft hat jetzt auch nicht zugenommen
jeder kann einfach nicht fassen wie sehr
sich ashley verändert hat der
prinzenrolle mit sprühsahne das
ekelhafte jetzt essen statt diesen
ganzen mist hier okay ganz kurz liebe
freundin von der ist doch mal ne fliege
oder so ich hab's vergessen ich finde es
wirklich nicht ob ihr video ihre lebens
die hier kritisiert und dabei einfach
aussieht wie in swarovski kristall
leuchter ich meine wo hat die bitte
überall glitzern lippe auf der linken
brust die sieht aus als wäre nebel eine
scheibe ist das ist dass mario okay
wisst ihr was ich gar nicht wissen
da kommt ja wieder was jetzt gemacht
zehn kilo angeschleppt eine wagenladung
ritter sport einkaufen
ich weiß was ich jetzt wieder glücklich
macht wie wäre es mit einem gutschein
für den freizeitpark bisschen aktivität
oder vielleicht doch einfach ein
spaziergang
also nichts gegen leute die nation leute
da habe ich früher auch mehr gerne
gemacht aber in dieser menge und wie man
sich allein vorstellt dass man den
ganzen tag nur muffins und chips und
gummibärchen
ich weiß doch was mich glücklich macht
ich finde übrigens auch komisch und gar
nicht so cool anspitzer wenn ich jetzt
in der beziehung wäre und mich wieder in
der beziehung pummelchen denn das alter
würde man sagen nahm ein kleiner fed
sagt ja ich habe dir was mitgebracht
oder du bist mein allerliebstes fuhren
söhnchen die waage soll endlich
gewissheit bringen
[Musik]
es kann ja nicht sagen lieber louis du
hast du isst oder du hast eindeutig den
falschen beruf also hör mal zu ich weiß
nicht was du beruflich so machst in der
schule oder so oder so eine ausbildung
machen ob das schon arbeit ist aber mit
dieser veranlagung solltest du wirklich
nur schweinezüchter werden ziel raus
aufs land machen die schweinezucht auf
und trifft ich nie wieder mit mädchen
bestimmt mehrere und ihr dumm ist sich
bringt daran schuld sie sich war gestern
noch im park bewegt sich einfach zu viel
das ist das problem gar nicht mehr
ich suche mir dann mal einen anderen
planeten zum beruf erfahren wie es ist
das maß zu nehmen war natürlich ein spaß
sollte ich muss ein echter wenn man
sagen du jetzt du bist echt ein
korrekter typ finde ich super von dir
dass du an der stelle nicht zum
drastischen mittel greifen und deine
freundin direkt in ketten legst sondern
hier einfach nur jede form von bewegung
verbietet was für ein cross leute das
von diesem video gewesen sein dass wir
wieder körperlich und seelisch
schwerstarbeit für mich mit diesem video
anzuschauen wenn jetzt wieder sehen
wollt wo leute sich ausnahmsweise mal
nicht pressen könnt ihr hier eine neue
folge von was das geht ab checken da war
ich auf der gamescom haben eltern und
ihre kinder zu gefragt zb wie viel ihre
kinder so packen und er kann sehr
unterschiedliche antworten raus sehr
interessant gibt es hier
trotz gut und 10.000 kalorien am tag
weiter denkt